‏all
time understand and
all
individ are con
notl
of
‏when each of us
we will come upon a do not understand
we do notehend
we are unsure of meaning
however we are always to accept
the same go with the narrations of our
prop
of the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
امنا به كل من عند ربنا
‏All
because
come to me
and with
Allah
things Allah things propet commands us
things Allahit
us ‏We may not understand value.
However, our spirit that we are t is
we hear and we obey
even if we don't understand that
understanding is not condition for our
adherence. We don't have to understand
everything in to everything Allah
commands us with.
الله
غفرانك ربنا
‏This is a very important lesson. This
is the most important lesson that we as
par can teach our children that we as
can with the next generation.
We can't teach our children the meaning
of every single ruling of every single
verse of the Quran.
‏That is what sch is thatance
and those shades of understanding that
takes decades
of ofearch
and learning and understanding
in order for us to understand all of the
ns and cr of the qu and
that's what sch are for
and likewi with the commandments and
prohibitions
الله سبحانه وتالى
change
‏teach our one thing that we can teach
the generation
is the attitude of the believer
we don't re something because we don't
understand it we don't re what said and
the prop
‏because
upur
viw and our current world view because
constantly changing
as a matter of fact if anyone of us were
to meet ourselves yesterday
i had a time machine and i went this
time machine and went and talked to
myself yesterday right here i would
disagree with
‏I would look down myself
how much more so last year 10 years from
now and many people fail to understand
is that in the moment right now when you
are arguing so when you are so
opinionated and you are thumping your
chest and diing in your heels that
you're
so
‏you are tomorrow yesterday
just remember that just remember that
next year you won agree with yourself
if you do agree with yourself next year
on everything this probably means that
you have not developed you have not
advanced
‏as constantly areyance
من عند ربنا
‏those things
and
theitud and spirit of the true believer
and in order for us to teach this to our
children in order for us to truly leave
this behind for the next generation
we have to really learn it ourselves.
‏We have to have conviction of it. And I
don't mean lip service, saying all the
right things, knowing all the jargon,
knowing all the words that make me sound
a whil my heart is far from where
is
ما تفعلون.
ஹى
[Silence]
البقره
الله سبحانه وتعالى
لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
وان تبدوا ما في انفسكم او تخفوه يحاسبكم
به الله
فشق ذلك على المسلمين
قالوا ما نخفي في صدورنا
وما نبديه يحاسبنا عليه الله
هذه مصيبه فان الانسان يستطيع ان يطيع
الله في الظاهر لكن باطن الانسان تمر في
قلب الانسان وفي خلبه خواطر وحواجس ووساوس
واشياء لا يدين الله سبحانه وتعالى بها
فان حاسبنا الله على ما تحدثنا
به نفوسنا هلكنا ولا بد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏belongs all that is heavens and all the
and if you all are to conceal what is in
your
man
will judge and bring you to for it
and the companions
were
they were
judging
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏ustable
what
do what we fail to do what we fail to
say this is something that we can almost
that we can almost handle
but in our heart of hearts in our minds
every human being has whispers have
thoughts have fleeting
whispers
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏haveul
how there is no way for us to pass that
judg
and so the companions
when this ver wased
said the companions upon learning this
verse came to the prophet
‏andes
and said
الله Allah comm
us
and
all those things and those things to the
best of ourility
but ‏verse we can't handle
we can't handle how can a person contr
every fleeting thought that goes through
their mind
and if a person is h to for that there's
no way for us to contr this we feel that
this is something that we are that is
expected of us that we can't do
even
sacrificing our own lives on the battle
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and that's notون
ان تكونوا كما قالت بنو اسرائيل سمعنا
وعصينا
بل قولوا سمعنا واطعنا غفرانك ربنا واليك
المصير
‏said
we hear and is that what
are you reing this he said rather say we
he and we ob
we of you your foriv and to you is our
that's what he said to them he said
don't make the same
isرا made if they
‏We hear and we disob you say we hear
and we obey.
Even if you think that you can't handle
it, even if it's more than you can bear
even if you don't understand it, do not
ever recept
it and ask forgiveness.
‏from
timeانك
ربنا المصير
سمعنا واطعنا غفرانك ربنا واليك المصير
[Arabic recitation]
لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض وان
تبدوا ما في انفسكم او تخفوه يحاسبكم
به الله
فيغفر لمن يشاء
فيعذب من يشاء ويغفر لمن يشاء والله على
كل شيء قدير
امن الرسول بما انزل اليه من ربه
والمؤمنون
كل امن بالله وملائكته وكتبه ورسله لا
نفرق بين احد من رسله
وقالوا سمعنا واطعنا
غفرانك ربنا واليك المصير
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها
لها ما كسبت وعليها ما اكتسبت
ربنا لا تؤاخذنا ان نسينا او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما حملته على
الذين من قبلنا
ربنا ولا تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به واعف
عنا واغفر لنا وارحمنا
انت مولانا
فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
فقال
تعالى قد فعلت
قد فعلت
متى غفر الله لهم لما تعلموا سمعنا واطعنا
قال قد فعلت
فاخبرنا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
ليس ثم مسلم
يتلو هذه الايات
يرجو الله ويخاف عذابه الا واجاب الله
سبحانه وتعالى دعاء
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره البقره
البقره
الله
سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
ناس واطعنا
ابو هريره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
البقره
asking الله
and seeking in him from what they him to
seek in Allah from except that Allah
will give them all they hope for and
save them from all they fear
but this is because
سمعنا واطعنا
مش عارفين قرعه ابوه
‏tell everything
and
you don't worry you don't have anything
newly
thought was so assur
it's just here to back you up not here
to teach you anything it's here to just
bolster every opinion and presupposition
you already have that's the
function of the qu it's not here to
change
‏Allah you
are
yes is that what the came to teach us or
is that the defeat
c opinion of someone who is to afraid to
look himself in the eye in the mirror
and not what he sees and work to
change it. There's a difference between
those two. ‏One has been forgiven and
one only continues to delute himself
more and more until he finally wants to
come back to the confused himself
where the path even
نسال
وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر لنا ذنوبنا نساله
تعالى انقننا سمعنا واطعنا نساله تعالى ان
يلقننا وان يغرس في قلوبنا في جذر قلوبنا
امنا به كل من عند ربنا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد
لبيان مقام التوحيد واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه وخليله وامينه على
وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه وقد جاهد في الله
حق جهاده حتى اتاه اليقين فاللهم صل على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين انك
حميد مجيد اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ازواجه
وذريته كما صليت على ال ابراهيم وبارك على
محمد وعلى ازواجه وذريته كما باركت على ال
ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا
على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه انك لا
تخلف الميعاد ربنا هب لنا من ازواج نا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار اللهم ربنا لا تحمل علينا
اصرا كما حملته على الذين من قبلنا ربنا
ولا تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به واعف عنا
واغفر لنا وارحمنا
انت مولانا فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
مولانا فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين مولانا
فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين اللهم اننا
نعوذ بك من درك الشقاء وسوء القضاء وشماته
الاعداء اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء ومنازل الشهداء
ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء والنصر
على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من الربا
ونعوذ بك من الزنا ونعوذ بك من الغلى
اللهم قنا عذابك يوم تبعث عبادك اللهم
اغفر لنا خطايانا وتب علينا انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم ات نفوسنا تقواها وزكها انت
خير من زكاها انت وليها ومولاها اللهم
اجعل لنا هذا الجمع المبارك جمعا مغفورا
جمعا مشهودا جمعا
منصورا يا رب العالمين اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشرك
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قدمت
الصلاه
قدت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
[Arabic recitation]
حاد بين المناكب وسب الفرج
‏are
teaches us
to our
nebors to our feet and anklors
on side of you
pleasck your make
الله
اكبر سبحانك بحمدك وتبارك اسمك وتعك
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض وان
تبدوا ما في انفسكم او تخفوه يحاسبكم
به الله
فيغفر لمن يشاء
ويعذب من يشاء
والله على كل شيء قدير
امن الرسول بما انزل اليه من ربه
والمؤمنون
كل امن بالله وملائكته
وكتبه ورسله لا نفرق بين احد من رسله
وقالوا سمعنا واطعنا
سمعنا واطعنا غفرانك ربنا واليك المصير
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها
لها ما كسبت وعليها ما اكتسبت ربنا لا
تؤاخذنا ان نسينا او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما حملته على
الذين من قبلنا
ربنا ولا تحملنا
ما لا طاقه لنا به واعف عنا
واغفر لنا وارحمنا
انت
مولانا فانصرنا
فانصرنا
على القوم الكافرين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر
السلام عليكم
அடமிச்சার
அடமிஸ்
বহজ বন্ড
‏also
in pry
s com 23
so you
can sign up for that pr by you want so
pleas make take advantage of the summer
camp as much as you canইশ
pleas